my father says never is a very powerful  powerful word word  you said we've never been paranoid are  you saying never as in 1776 or never as  in 40 years 60 years 80 years 100 years  well i'm speaking relative terms  compared to the north koreans and the  chinese and the russians and our  contemporary adversaries i don't think  we've ever  been as paranoid as they  and including founding fathers oh  including founding fathers if we  understand maybe we're using the word  paranoid in different ways i mean a  paranoid paranoia  is a dysfunctional psychological  condition  that means that you live in a fantasy  world where you imagine that you are  surrounded by threats some of them may  be real but many of them are not and i i  think  i don't think that describes america in  any phase of its history if anything we  have been a nation of optimists  throughout  the founding fathers